all right now we're going to do
something I don't think has ever been
done at the Oscars while we reset the
stage for a very special performance we
invited viewers watching from all over
to send questions for the stars and now
I'm going to ask some of the Stars some
of the questions that the viewers sent
in starting with Malala who is here
Malala
welcome
thank you so much great to have you here
and congratulations on your movie this
question is from Joanne nicolatis from
Brooklyn New York she asked your work on
human rights and education for women and
children is an inspiration as the
youngest Nobel Prize winner in history I
was wondering do you think Harry Styles
spit on Chris Pine
thank you
I only talk about peace
that's you know what that's why you're
Malala nobody else is
that's a great answer Malala the winner
is Malala land everybody
and the next question is from Joey
perello from Las Vegas for Colin Farrell
haven't seen Joey in years well Joey
would like to ask you he said Colin I
loved your performance in the Banshees
of industrian my question is what were
you saying in the movie
I'd like him to go on YouTube and check
out SNL last night and he'll have a good
idea and that way he'll figure it out
all right thank you very much and I
apologize for Joey that's if you and the
donkey go out after text me okay
look at this creepy thracky again
congratulations next question is for oh
Jessica Chastain where is she Jessica hi
Jessica this question uh there's no name
on this one it says Jessica was it
difficult filming your movie The Martian
because your co-star Matt Damon can't
read and smells like dog medicine
excellent wonderful all right
um another fun fact oh they feed Matt
Damon peanut butter on set to make it
look like he's talking that's
cocaine bear leave Malala Alone come
all right we got to get this guy out of
here please say hello from Black Panther
deny Guerrera
[Applause]